what's good everyone Michael and Jimmy
here coming to you from CES 2018 and we
just saw what in videos showing off and
they're sweet and we saw a very big
monitor display tell us what what it is
generally yeah sure so the videos that
the bfg display and technically it
stands for big format gaming display but
we all know that stands for big [ __ ]
game in this place and they consider it
a more of a gaming display as opposed to
a TV because even though it looks like a
TV and it's 65 inches but what separates
it is that it doesn't actually have a TV
tuner but what it does have are some
amazing specs so it's 4k 120 Hertz
supports HDR g-sync
has a very fast response time that's
more akin to like a typical gaming
monitor like you see game monitor and I
think most gaming monitors are around
like 5 milliseconds or below most TVs
are around 2025 milliseconds so gaming
on a large screen TV isn't a really good
experience whereas it is here what do
you think about it used automation yeah
we saw it in action
they were playing destiny 2 on PC off of
this display and like you mentioned that
the response times of regular TVs aren't
exactly like the best at least compared
to what we see in gaming monitors so
what we have here is all of the things
that you would want out of a gaming
monitor like the response time refresh
rate and on top of that we get HDR so
you pack all those specs into like a 65
inch TV and then what you get is
essentially in a large gaming monitor
you know when I hook up my PC to my TV I
do notice ghosting sometimes input lag
and you know that's fine with a lot of
other games like Sinclair games that I
play but if I'm playing like competitive
shooters especially like for me I play a
lot of Counter Strike you know you want
to make sure that all your monitor specs
are on point and here you know now we
can actually play it on a big screen
you know without sacrificing the faster
features that we get out of a typical
gaming monitor yeah it's also has a
thousand into brightness so it can get
like really bright when playing we're
seeing somebody play destiny and they're
like some light shafts or like a bright
but it's also HDR which means that get
really deep black levels as well it's
shaping up to be an awesome super large
gaming monitor where do you think people
will actually
because it is supposed to be give him
honor but it's yeah large yeah I have a
couple thoughts on that you know
obviously being 65 inches it's something
you want to put in a living room or a
space that you have as a home theater
thing is also you know oh it's not a TV
but it does have built-in Nvidia shield
in it so you get essentially that
streaming service that most Smart TVs
have so you can connect to whatever you
know Netflix Hulu Amazon video right
there and you can also like stream games
off of that if you want it to and then
you know it also has an Ethernet port
too so it doesn't have to rely on a
wireless signal all the time and that is
what we see out of TVs now is that we're
not subscribing to cable we're looking
at these streaming services and then you
know that's built into the TV like other
Smart TVs here and it also does support
you know HDMI and DisplayPort so you
can't hook up you like your Xbox a place
that should do it as well so pricing is
probably gonna be really expensive yeah
video saying is about the same as like I
really high-end like 4k TV with like a
really high refresh rate and then from a
release date Nvidia is targeting you
know summer and also I should mention
that you know Nvidia is creating the
standard here they're not actually
manufacturing the displays it's actually
going to be manufactured by HP AC a
masseuse so that was one of the biggest
things that we saw so far at CES stay
tuned to game spot comm for all of our
coverage thanks for watching